what's going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 basics tutorial video
in this video we're going to be talking
about a multi-line print so multi-line
print is kind of like a multi-line
comment only you're going to actually
print it out to console in multiple
lines
so whenever i started programming it
really it took me a long time to figure
this one out
i had no idea that you could do a
multi-line print and so sometimes you
want to make you know kind of cute
gooeys and just cute text-based
ascii gooeys
and
i would literally code those guys by
line so i would do print and then the
single line then print the next line
print the next line and then i found out
you don't have to do that
um no one ever told me this i was
actually looking at someone's code and i
noticed that they were doing it and i
was like oh my gosh you can you had no
idea you could do this so anyway i'm
just going to show you guys real quick
multi-line print
so to do a multi-line print you just do
print
and then one two three just like a
multi-line comment you can see it even
kind of wants to comment it out
one two three and as long as it's within
a print statement it's gonna print it
and so kind of an easy way to work
around this is to do something like this
and then put your print in between
the
uh
this area here that way because usually
if you're doing a multi-line print it's
because you've made some sort of design
or something so to do it nicely i would
do it this way
so
make your space here
and
uh we'll just say like you know so this
is a simple
multi
line print
pretty cool
huh or
a
so you can run it i crack myself up i
know you guys are just loving it anyway
so this is a simple multi-line print
obviously since we had these extra
spaces here that's why i did that we
could take them away like that
and get less of that now
um
so the next thing i want to show you
guys is like you can do you know stuff
like this um
we'll make a box okay
so we do that
copy this
paste it
and
oops
this box needs to be a little taller
guys
do you like this
oh my goodness
i think i'm broken today everybody
haven't had much sleep
uh
oh my gosh okay
hey
making a box
this is a lot of effort for making a
single box
okay and then we'll just say uh
box
all right it's not centered oh my
goodness
all right that's not centered either i
don't think anyway run it and now we
printed out our box you guys get the
point so again sometimes you want to do
like kind of like gooeys like this you
want to make some boxes and organize
some data yourself that's how you can do
it with multi-line print uh so anyways
if you guys have any questions or
comments pretty simple things i'm not
sure anybody's gonna have a question
about this uh but if you do leave them
in the section below as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time